A WITNESS IN HIS OWN CASE.
REQUIRED TO DISQUALIFY HIMSELF
GET HERE WITH REACTION TO ALL OF
US, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
SARA CARTER, AUTHOR OF "THE
NUMBER ONE BEST SELLER, THE
RUSSIA HOAX, AUTHOR OF THE YEAR
FORWARD TO THE PUBLISHED MUELLER
REPORT, ALAN DERSHOWITZ.
POWERFUL QUESTIONS, I SUMMED
THEM UP, BUT YOU HAVE A LOT MORE
DETAIL.
>> THE MOST IMPORTANT QUESTION
WAS THE LAST ONE, MAY 16TH,
2016, MUELLER INTERVIEWING TO
REPLACE COMEY, ISN'T IT TRUE
THAT YOU DISCUSSED WITH THE
PRESIDENT IN THE OVAL OFFICE,
TWO WITNESSES THEY ARE, THE
REASONS WHY THE PRESIDENT FIRED
JAMES COMEY?
IF THE ANSWER IS YES, WE DID
DISCUSS IT, THAT MEANS UNDER THE
REGULATIONS, MUELLER WAS
REQUIRED TO DISQUALIFY HIMSELF
AND SAY I CAN'T TAKE THE JOB
BECAUSE HE'S A WITNESS IN HIS
OWN CASE.
YOU CAN'T BE A PROSECUTOR AND A
CHIEF WITNESS SIMULTANEOUSLY.
SO THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT.
BUT AT THE TOP OF THE LIST, AS
YOU SAW, THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING IS, HOW COULD YOU
INVESTIGATE RUSSIAN COLLUSION
AND INTERFERENCE IN THE ELECTION
WITHOUT INVESTIGATING HOW
HILLARY CLINTON'S CAMPAIGN AND
THE DNC PAID FOR RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION AND FED IT TO THE
MEDIA AND THE FBI TO INFLUENCE
THE ELECTION?
I MEAN, IT'S JUST ASTONISHING TO
ME THAT THEY ARE JUST A PASSING
REFERENCE TO THE DOSSIER IN
MUELLER'S 448 PAGES.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, PROFESSOR,
CIVIL LIBERTIES ARE IMPORTANT,
GREGG RAISES A GOOD QUESTION.
HE INVESTIGATED PHARAOH
VIOLATIONS, A BROAD MANDATE, AND
HE DID INVESTIGATE, LET'S
SEE, TAXI MEDALLIONS AND LOAN
APPLICATIONS, DECADES-OLD TAXES
THAT WEREN'T PAID -- BY THE WAY,
PAY YOUR TAXES AND DON'T LIE ON
A LOAN APPLICATION, DUMB IDEA.
WITH ALL OF THAT SAID, HOW DO
YOU THEN MISS THE DOSSIER ISSUE?
HOW DO YOU THEN MISS LYING TO A
FISA COURT JUDGE TO TAKE AWAY
THE CIVIL LIBERTIES OF NOT ONLY
ONE INDIVIDUAL, BUT SPY ON A
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN IN A
MULTITUDE OF WAYS, INCLUDING
LYING AND OBTAINING A FISA
WARRANT UNDER PREMEDITATED,
FALSE PRETENSES, COMMITTING
FRAUD BECAUSE YOU WERE WARNED
COMPLETELY THAT IT WAS
UNVERIFIABLE?
>> WELL, THE IRONY IS THAT ALL
OF THE QUESTIONS THE DEMOCRATS
WANT TO ASK HIM, HE'S NOT
ENTITLED TO ANSWER.
HE CAN'T ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
INVOLVING THE INVESTIGATION OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP OR HIS CAMPAIGN,
BECAUSE THAT WAS THE ESSENCE OF
THE REPORT.
THEY DECIDED THERE WAS NO CASE
FOR PROSECUTION, AND JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT REGULATIONS AND
TRADITIONS SAY THAT'S IT, YOU
DECIDED NOT TO PROSECUTE, DON'T
DO WHAT COMEY DID.
DON'T TALK ABOUT MIGHT HAVE
BEEN, SAY THAT SHE WAS SLOPPY
WITH HER USE OF THE EMAILS, AND
DON'T SAY THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
MIGHT HAVE, B, C, D, YOU'VE
ALREADY SAID IT.
THE IRONY IS THE QUESTIONS THE
REPUBLICANS WANT TO ASK ABOUT
ALL OF THE ISSUES THAT YOU AND
GREGG HAVE MENTIONED, ARE
COMPLETELY APPROPRIATE.
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT IN THE
REPORT.
AND THEY ARE ENTITLED TO ASK WHY
ISN'T IT IN THE REPORT?
WHY DID YOU PICK THESE PEOPLE TO
BE IN THE INVESTIGATION?
WHAT ABOUT THE FISA WARRANTS?
WHAT ABOUT THE STEELE DOSSIER?
ANYTHING THAT IS NOT IN THE
REPORT --
>> Sean: PROFESSOR, YOU ARE
VERY CLEAR, HE DOES NOT HAVE THE
RIGHT TO SAY I WANT TO ANSWER
THAT, EITHER.
>> NO, HE CAN'T SAY HE WON'T
ANSWER THAT.
HE IS UNDER SUBPOENA, AND IF THE
REPUBLICANS ASKING THAT
QUESTION, EVEN THOUGH HE IS IN
THE MINORITY, HE HAS TO ANSWER.
HE REFUSES TO ANSWER IT, THEY
WON'T VOTE TO HAVE HIM IN
CONTEMPT BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE A MAJORITY, BUT HE IS
OBLIGATED AS A LAWYER AND
OFFICER OF THE COURT TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS, HE IS UNDER OATH
TO TELL THE TRUTH, THE WHOLE
TRUTH, NOTHING BUT THE TRUTH.
I'M A DEMOCRAT, I HATE TO SEE
THE DEMOCRATS SHOOT THEMSELVES
IN THE FOOT, BUT THEY BOX
THEMSELVES IN --
>> Sean: WHO WOULD'VE THOUGHT
THAT THEY WOULD COME.
SEAN HANNITY AND PROFESSOR
DERSHOWITZ, WE AGREE ON SO MUCH
ABOUT ISRAEL AND THE
MIDDLE EAST, ET CETERA, WE
REALLY DO.
BUT WE ARE REALLY FIGHTING FOR,
LET'S SEE, OH, CIVIL LIBERTIES?
YOU CAN'T UNMASK AMERICAN
CITIZENS WITHOUT A WARRANT?
YOU CAN'T COMMIT A FRAUD ON A
FISA COURT?
>> LET ME TELL YOU WHAT ELSE YOU
CAN'T DO.
YOU CAN'T HAVE PROSECUTORS GOING
IN FRONT OF CONGRESS AND
EXPLAINING WHY THEY DIDN'T
PROSECUTE THE AVERAGE AMERICAN.
IF YOU HAVE THE AFRICAN-AMERICAN
BUSINESSMAN UNDER INVESTIGATION
AND HE IS NOT PROSECUTED,
CONGRESS AND I WAS TRYING TO
ESTABLISH A PRECEDENT WHEREBY
THEY CAN CALL A PROSECUTOR AND
SAY, OH, YOU DIDN'T CHARGE HIM,
WHY NOT?
WHAT ABOUT THIS EVIDENCE?
TELL US ABOUT THE OTHER
EVIDENCE.
IT UNDERCUTS THE PERCEPTION OF
INNOCENCE, UNDERCUTS THE
TRADITIONS OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, AND IT UNDERCUTS THE
RULE OF LAW.
TODAY, IT'S THE REPUBLICANS THAT
ARE VICTIMS.
TOMORROW, IF THE DEMOCRATS BEAR
THE DAY AFTER TOMORROW IT IS YOU
AND ME.
ANY AMERICAN CAN BE SUBJECT TO
THIS IN THE DEMOCRATS ESTABLISH
A PRECEDENT ALLOWING A
PROSECUTOR TO TESTIFY ABOUT WHY
HE DIDN'T CHARGE SOMEBODY WITH A
CRIME.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, I KNOW THE
MEDIA MOB, SCHIFF, WHO WE KNOW
IT -- BY THE WAY, WE HAVE HIM ON
TAPE COLLUDING WITH RUSSIANS TO
GET DIRT ON DONALD TRUMP.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE THE TAPE.
WE HAVE THOSE PICTURES.
I KNOW YOU LIKE THAT, PROFESSOR.
BUT SARA, AS WE GO OVER THIS,
PROFESSOR AND GREGG ARE RAISING
THE BEST POINTS.
REPUBLICANS ARE SALIVATING NOW
TO GET HIM IN THAT CHAIR.
>> OH, THEY ARE.
LAWMAKERS HAVE INFORMED ME THAT
THEY ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO
INTERVIEWING AND SPEAKING WITH
ROBERT MUELLER.
I THINK ONE QUESTION THAT IS
VITALLY IMPORTANT, AND GREGG AND
ALAN BOTH BROUGHT IT UP, IT IS
THE FACT, WHY DIDN'T HE
EXPAND -- BECAUSE HE HAD THE
LATITUDE, HE HAD THE LATITUDE TO
LOOK INTO ALL THINGS RUSH OUT.
WHY DIDN'T HE LOOK INTO THE
PEOPLE THAT CHRISTOPHER STEELE
ALLEGEDLY GOT THIS INFORMATION
FROM?
WHICH WAS RUSSIANS, ACCORDING TO
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
A LARGER PART IS THE DOSSIER,
WITH HIS INFORMATION, PLANTED BY
THE RUSSIANS.
SO THE QUESTION THAT I WOULD
HAVE IS MR. MUELLER, DID YOU ADD
ALL LOOK INTO THE OTHER SIDE?
CHRISTOPHER STEELE CONTACT -- BY
THE WAY, CHRISTOPHER STEELE IS A
FOREIGN SPY -- DID YOU LOOK INTO
THOSE CONTACTS WITH RUSSIANS
THAT HE HAD THAT HELP FEED THE
INFORMATION INTO THIS FALSE
DOSSIER?
THAT'S GOING TO BE SIGNIFICANTLY